vestige ordonné d'une nuit sans violence
dans un centre-ville toujours paralysées
par des résidents temporaires déterminé
à tenir le coup à oui bon je pense que
les camions dont ils vont rester ici
tant que ça bougera paul cayard pas
d'action du gouvernement car est gratuit
c'est les jo jo canada les québécois
la vaccination obligatoire des
camionneurs transfrontalier est devenue
un catalyseur
les manifestants réclament la fin du
masque la fin du code vaccinale la fin
de l'immunisation obligatoire est depuis
48 heures ils ont sentiment d'avoir
l'oreille du gouvernement
et ces gens là sont tannés je les
comprends il faut donc maintenant faire
en sorte que le gouvernement leur donne
un peu d'espoir 1 cela le gouvernement
répond qu'au delà de la fatigue c'est
encore la science qui doit primer nous
allons continuer de poursuivre les
mesures nécessaires pour protéger les
gens et pour mettre fin à la cavale 19
c'est pas un rassemblement de
camionneurs à ottawa qui constitue un
avis scientifique au gouvernement
rien pour calmer l'ardeur de ses poids
lourds près à portu et de leur klaxon la
reprise des travaux parlementaires
demain
une perspective particulièrement
désagréable pour les habitants du
secteur dont la patience a atteint ses
limites sans cesse le tournis ses 116
l'intimidation beaucoup de résidents
nous contactent ne pas d'une partageant
qu'ils ont paraît il on parle de sortir
de la maison puis dans la maison c'est
vivable justement à part le bruit des
camions
premier temps la capitale peut être se
permettre d'être paralysé personne n'ose
pour l'instant offrir de réponse ici
daniel thibault radio canada ottawa